potterheads how well do you really know
the marauders
because there are plenty of secrets that
only fans who've read every sentence of
every harry potter book will know
many years before harry and his squad
got their invitations to hogwarts there
was another group of students who were
just as interesting
of course we're talking about the
marauders we've dug up all the crucial
facts about james potter
sirius black remus lupin and peter
pettigrew that would have made a massive
difference had they been included in the
movies
from major plot points to key character
details even the most
dedicated fans will be shocked by some
of these revelations
let's give it a try do you feel ready
in the movies the last we see of
wormtail is when he collapses in the
basement of malfoy manor in the deathly
hallows part 1.
but his actual end is pretty different
in the books harry confronts his dad's
former friend
reminding wormtail that he saved his
life four years earlier so that means he
owes harry a favor
and guess what wormtail pauses and lets
harry escape
and because of that disloyalty to his
master his life
ends lord voldemort had fixed it so
wormtail's own silver hand would turn
on him and choke him in such a situation
it's not just peter pettigrew who is
dishonorable in the past
there's the time that sirius and james
pranked severus snape by sending him
into the whomping willow
doesn't sound too bad it will though
when you realize remus had just
disappeared down there to transform into
a werewolf
that could have ended snape's life and
that's far from a prank
isn't it sirius was seriously off the
rails in their fifth year
anyone who's seen the movie knows that
james was pretty mean to snape
we see that when harry dips into snape's
worst memory in the order of the phoenix
and he watches his dad taunting his
potions professor right in front of a
group of students
but what we don't see is that it was
actually thanks to james that snape
didn't get attacked by remus and the
whomping will of that fateful day
harry's father realized that their
so-called prank could be the end of
snape and so james called it off
of course that one good deed doesn't
excuse james for all his other bad ones
in that memory we also see james using a
spell to hang snape upside down
we get that he was unkind to snape but
his bullying behavior didn't stop there
fans of the book will know that james
was pretty unkind to other students too
he used to regularly hex them james even
made someone's head double in size
in fact he had such a reputation for it
lily described him as an arrogant toe
rag in the books
we get a feel for the history behind
severus and lilly's friendship when we
watch snape's memories in the deathly
hallows part two
they connect over their magical ability
before they even get to hogwarts but we
don't understand
the depth of their relationship from the
films or how their friendship ended
sure there's the moment snape calls lily
when he's embarrassed about her standing
up for him but in the deathly hallows
book we learn why
lily finished their friendship once and
for all it was down to his death eater
friends
lily could see that snape had chosen his
way and she'd chosen hers
in snape's memories in the film we also
see lily's first meeting with james
she smiles at him as they introduce
themselves to each other after they've
been sorted into gryffindor
it gives the impression that lily and
james were friends from the get-go
but actually as any fan of the books
will know lily was not a fan of james
nor his friends
it wasn't until james got his act
together for the final year of hogwarts
that lily started to like him
he was head boy and she was head girl oh
and in the books
they first met on the hogwarts express
in the movies it's a mystery why
wormtail was chosen as the potter's
secret keeper
after all surely sirius would have been
a much better choice
he was james's best buddy he was harry's
godfather
and james wanted him to take on that
position so why wasn't he chosen
the books revealed that sirius believed
he was a target for voldemort
and that's why he let wormtail take the
role he thought that wormy would be less
conspicuous than him
but as we all know that was a massive
mistake
on that secret keeper theme here's an
even more shocking revelation from the
books that the movies left out
sirius wasn't suspicious of wormtail he
was suspicious about remus
he started to think his friend was a spy
for voldemort why so
because voldemort promised werewolves
free reign when he was in power
that's a big misjudgment on sirius's
part right at least he eventually
apologized to remus for suspecting him
and of course remus forgave him
instantly
the fact that tonks and remus had ascend
together is barely mentioned in the
movies
when harry is with the spirits in the
forbidden forest we briefly hear mention
of remus son and remus hate your son
others will tell him what his mother and
father died but in the books
teddy lupin is much more present his
parents talk about him during the battle
of hogwarts
and guess what they did actually film a
scene where tonks and remus discuss
teddy he'll sleep till dawn and snore
like his father
but it got cut a grown-up teddy also
appears in the epilogue of the final
book
kissing victoire fleur and bill
weasley's daughter but he isn't anywhere
to be seen in the 19 years later movie
scene
actor luke newberry was cast as teddy
but his appearance was cut too
in the movies it seems like tonk and
remus are a happy couple without any
marital issues
tonks is totally supportive of her other
half but in the books we get a different
story
jk rowling explores the pressures that
their relationship's facing
specifically how much remus struggles
with it he can't fully believe that
tonks is so accepting of him
to the point that in the deathly hallows
novel remus plans to abandon his wife
and unborn child to join harry
it's not because he isn't dedicated to
his family it's because he's terrified
of the repercussions of a werewolf
having a baby with a human
and he doesn't want to bring shame on
them fortunately harry talked remus into
going home
the prisoner of azkaban film completely
omits any mention of how sirius escaped
from jail
it's a seriously impressive feat given
that the prison is so closely guarded by
dementors
but we do learn in the third book how
sirius got away
he explains that he starved himself for
months and got thin enough to squeeze
through the bars
that explains why he looked so skinny in
the film but why didn't the dementor
sense his presence
because he was filled with hope about
tracking down worm tail
and the dementors can't detect hope
of course we know from harry's
eavesdropping session in the prisoner of
azkaban movie
that sirius was falsely imprisoned for
supposedly finishing off wormtail and
leading voldemort to his dear friends
james and lily but what we don't learn
in the film is that sirius also took the
wrap for wormtail's other evil actions
in the book we discovered that on the
night of their confrontation
wormtail causes an explosion that ended
the lives of 13 muggles
we know from the movie that sirius was
unfailingly loyal to james and lily but
it's only fans of the book who could
know that james was just as dedicated to
sirius
at the end of their fifth year at
hogwarts sirius ran away from his awful
death eater family
and the potter family offered him refuge
taking him into their home
it's not just serious that james gave
shelter to though he also financially
supported remus after they left school
because no one would give a werewolf a
job jk rowling revealed this indication
of what a good man james was
despite his wayward youth just say that
i'm used to it right now
we see how vicious the whomping willow
is in both the chamber of secrets and
prisoner of azkaban movies and we just
take it for granted that there'd be an
aggressive tree in the grounds of
hogwarts
but the books actually explain why the
willow is there and it's all down to
remus
when dumbledore let him study at the
school despite the fact that he was a
werewolf
the headmaster planted the whomping
willow to give remus safe passage to the
shrieking shack
remus is also responsible for the
formation of the marauders map
and the marauders themselves but we
wouldn't know this from watching the
films
in the prisoner of azkaban novel remus
reveals that when his friends discovered
he was a werewolf
they did something that made his
transformations not only bearable but
the best times of his life
they became anna mad guy prongs the stag
pad foot the dog and wormtail the rat
were created
they invented the map so they could
sneak around as animals and not get
caught
which of these secrets do you think most
deserves to have been included in the
movies
be sure to sound off in the comments
section and hit that like button if you
want to see a prequel movie all about
the marauders school days
thanks for watching